so hello everyone i'll be talking about
super search with open search and python
my name is eliza showa
i work for ivan has a developer advocate
we do our best to manage open source
databases for you i also i'm also very
active in the pilots community and also
in the phyto community to be honest
i
managed the pilotism munich group and
yeah you can follow me here on my
twitter account or you can also check it
out the twitter account of my company
so what is the agenda for today
so i'll talk about what is open search
and why should you consider open search
in your project
and i also will explain how can you
write search queries and i will do it
with a demo
so wish me
luck so what is open search so open
search as you can see
as you can hear in the name it has open
open is actually open source so it means
that you can download and you can try
out and you can also change the code
and you can contribute back to those uh
to this project
if you know elast search open search
it's a direct fork of alaskage version 7
or 10. so if you are familiar with a
last search
you will be familiar with open source as
well but now they are different projects
and so on it's a search engine so it's
also in the name and i would say that
actually the super power of open of open
search is being a search engine but it's
not only that you can use open search to
actually store a huge amount of data uh
you can clear basically near real time
and you can also uh use it to visualize
data
so open search comes with open source
dashboards that you can do that
so it's pretty cool uh some other things
i've also researched is that if you are
familiar with rest api it does have
support for rest api and also you can
use in different languages uh has
official
clients for python from node.js from go
from yeah of course for python
so
why should you consider using open
search
when i think about open search i try to
summarize what are some of the super
powers that open such habit
and i try to think about really a
superhero
so one of the powers of open search is
that is multilingual so it has support
for more than 30 languages which means
that when you are sending data when you
send your json data to open source you
can actually specify the language and
you can do more configurations to
support those languages so i would say
that open search if it was a hero would
speak more than 30 languages
it also can read your mind uh because it
does have support for auto completion uh
so i think you may haven't seen some uh
ultra engineers when you typing and kind
of the engine tries to see oh what's
relevant for this person and try to come
up with some suggestions so i would say
that is also a way that open search does
it helps you to do auto completion if
you configure correct
and it you can imagine if
open search was a would be a superhero
and could read so many languages uh
could open such also understand my
broken english
yes
so if you acquire with uh wrong or
misspelling or miss typo open search
also would you can configure it for
searching so you can still get some
results from it
and the last i would say is dynamic
mapping which means you don't need to
specify when you're sending data to open
search you don't need to specify all the
fields and have a
schema already you can just send an open
session will try to figure out from the
data that you send which kind of type
the fields will have
you can also configure the
the mapping before
but you can use dynamic mapping so i
found this really cool and also those
would be some of the super powers
additionally is open source
so
now i will show you how can you write
some search queries with open search
the first
thing we need actually i have it here
demo uh open search python dive in and
we need the python client for the open
search uh we need also lots of data i
chose food
so in case i come up here with different
recipes and you find the interesting you
can tell me i will send you
so the first square that i will show you
is the match one so i'll go to the
command line
okay so i have it here let me see okay
it's a little bit
down but it's okay so i have it here uh
the repository and
let's wait a little bit for
the person so you can see it here on the
readme
i have a here that read me would explain
where you can get this data set uh how
the repository structure is and a little
bit more about what kind of queries you
can find it
and during the presentation i'll be
using this one here the search.pi
so we don't need to worry about this i
will go over uh with the synth about the
syntax later but yeah let's see what the
match query can give us so i'll be using
pi
python
search.pi
match and i will look in the title so
first i'll give you the field
and i will look for some combination and
the more interesting one that i could
come up was chocolate and garlic i think
they're great separated and i want to
see if i can find anything where they
are together
of course i will find this
but yeah let's see
so
you can see it here that
window finds chocolate garlic cuban
bread and we find some waters like just
garlic bread garlic shrimp and so on
you may be thinking why do i get steel
things just with garlic if i'm using the
match the match queer so by default the
match square use the operator or
which means that will be when we do this
query it's actually checking for
chocolate or garlic
so one way we could actually specify
okay i actually just want words that
have chocolate i just want results in my
documents that have chocolate and garlic
so what i could do i could give it an
operator like the end one
and you see that now we can get only the
cuba bread
which i think it would be interesting
for me to try out
uh but yeah one thing that you can see
it here is that even though
i
yeah let's see actually how is the
syntax so you can understand how would
you do that in python
so here first of all i have to
create the client uh and i have one of
the methods called dot search that will
help me to build the square so i give it
the index
which i index my data beforehand and i
also have to build the query uh the
query it's in a dictionary and i define
it here the word keyword query and i
have to give it the query type
open search has many query types i will
show you today three but for example
this time we gave it match so this would
be one of it we have to give the field
name that we are interested to look for
the results
and we have to also give what kind of
words or what kind of centers we are
looking on there and also the operator
if you don't give the operator there is
the default one or
so that would be like how the syntax
work
in the code and you see the result here
but coming back to the code
if we actually
change the position
between garlic and chocolate and see if
we can still get some result
so if we do it here you see that
actually match
does not care does not care
does not care about the order of the
words
but let's suppose i do have two names in
my name and if you are looking for me in
a database uh if you exchange my name so
put different you will find someone else
so sometimes the order does matter and
what kind of query you would use in this
case so there is another one called
matte phrase
that we can check out how it works so
for example
i will also use search.pi
so i have an interface here that i did
the typer and that's why i can easily
just type here what i want and it will
give me the results
but you can check out the code how could
you do that
like on your own so here i have for
example match phrase and i'll be looking
in title
it's in tito
and let's suppose that i will look for
cake
and coconut
let's see what will come up
nothing come out uh and you may be i was
wondering like i have here 20 000
recipes and i don't believe that there
is no
cake
coconut
but the thing is my mother tongue is
portuguese so sometimes i
yeah i get a bit confused about the
order of the adjective and the solution
to
and this is an interesting one because
you have to think about your user right
so if actually i changed it here the
order
and i put coconut cake this is correct
because it's correct english right
but let's suppose that and then we can
get here a coconut cake and so on and so
forth but let's suppose i have still the
wrong order
so if i had
cake and coconut
how could i still
tell
who's the mad phrase so i tell that yes
i do care that these two words are have
a order but i want to give some
flexibility so yeah maybe there is some
word in between maybe you can exchange
the uh
this the word and so on so that is
something that is very cool about the
match phrase that you can give a slope
so for example if here i get a slope of
one
then you can see that now i can get some
mates so i can see that there is cake
with coconut uh and basically there is
cake but there is a word in between and
how is that the match phrase actually
works and why is that that you can give
some slope for it
so i don't have it here something about
the match phrase just where to
understand what kind of flexibility how
this slope works so the slope is the
acceptable distance between two words
so they could be like switch it they
could be you could have words in between
uh but you have to account for those
distances so here for example our
document come out was cake with coconut
and the aquarium was cake coconut
how did it actually give me a slope of
one how did it actually match it
so if we just uh yeah
switch coconut from the position two to
the position three we could have a match
here
so i guess this was a piece of cake it's
very simple to understand but it's how
the principle of the slope works
and if we go back actually let me
continue here i press the wrong button
so yeah let's continue uh another one
that i want to show you today is the
fuzzy ware so i told you that uh
open search does uh allow fuzziness and
the fuzziness would be like for example
you miss type some words and you have to
you don't expect that the user write
exactly exactly what they want so you
have to be a bit flexible about your
queries and the first query would work
like this
for the first square i tried to find a
word that i found a bit
confusing for me so would be the word
dessert
because it's very close to desert and
they are very similar dessert or desert
so
we're gonna be looking for desert and
try to find something with it
so let's suppose i mistype it and i look
for desert here
oops uh my bed
so i have to give a if i have to give a
fuzziness level so for example i would
give house default zero so i'm not
allowing any kind of fuzziness and you
see here i get no results but if i go
here and i give default like if i change
to one you can see it here that now
actually the word desert will map with
this word here
and why do i need just one slope
because uh
i only have extra s
but maybe you are thinking but why
the word
what i'm querying is actually lowercase
and what i'm seeing there is actually
uppercase this is a good question
if someone asked i'll answer
but yeah let's go back to the to the
first square and so how could you build
this query so basically you will replace
the word false
the type of query for the word fuzz and
you would give the type of what field
you are looking for in your question
and here will be the value would be
desert
the one which is dry not the sweet one
and the fastness would be one and in
this case i can still get some results
here
so
that's what very short introduction
about open search but i hope you
understood the basics
and you may
want to try out you can check out this
i'll add more queries there
thank you
[Applause]
you